thank you so much for coming out tonight
raise a glass and toast to All of You
Beautiful People
cheers Anna said there was a man
outside he follow me over the wood Brave
it get away from the
window
you all
[Music]
right it's amazing you didn't catch the
man well I haven't been sick in years
you just got lost a minute ago no I
didn't get lost listen I apologize if I
made you feel uncomfortable the other
night it's fine it's not fine my uncle
talks about you a lot my dad and I were
maybe thinking you could care for him
during the day all you'd have to do is
be there go on walks and
stuff why did you follow me home from
the
party
or do you only remember when it's
convenient I don't
[Music]
remember you don't know what you're
doing you're not able to make rational
decisions right
now why did you leave things were just
getting
complicated what do you mean
why did you and mom stop talking when
your mother was your age I she was out
of control no was
me really
[Music]
hard hi welcome back the usual for you
oh yeah what's the
usual
I don't
know no do you remember her
[Music]
no